أعتقد أنه من العدل أن تقول إنك
ترغب في مزيد من الشفافية هنا وقبل لحظة كنت
نتحدث عن
حقيقة أن هذه يمكن أن تكون
لحظة قابلة للتعليم وتساعد حقًا
الجمهور وهذا شيء
اعترفت به العائلة المالكة و
وقال الملك تشارلز في تنبيهه للجمهور أنه
سيدخل المستشفى ولكن
ما رأيك في هذا التصريح حيث
يتحدثون عن نوع من السرطان
ويقولون إنه تم تشخيص إصابته
بنوع من السرطان لكنهم لا يذكرون هذا
النوع  السرطان أم لا، هذا لا
يغذي المزيد من
التكهنات، نعم، أعتقد أن هذا أمر
مشؤوم جدًا في الواقع أه أثناء دخوله
المستشفى الأصلي بسبب
تضخم البروستاتا الحميد، لقد بذل القصر قصارى جهده
لتذكير الجمهور بأنه لم يكن مصابًا
بالسرطان  كان من المهم بالنسبة
لهم أن يعرفوا أنه لم يكن مصابًا بالسرطان
الآن حيث أن هناك
تشخيصًا مختلفًا أه يبدو أن القصر متحفظ جدًا في
إعطاء أه أي تفاصيل على الإطلاق
وهذا يؤدي فقط إلى تأجيج
التكهنات والقلق بين  أه
الجمهور أعتقد أنه عندما يواجه العامة عندما
تواجه الشخصيات العامة أمراضًا خطيرة مثل
مرض القلب وأه والسرطان، كما
تعلمون، تعرفون الوصمة، تعرفون
تلك التشخيصات التي تعرفونها، وتتركون
هذا النوع من الهواء بعيدًا عن ذلك
وتكون صريحًا معهم  لقد قطع الجمهور شوطًا
طويلًا بالفعل،
أراد الملك استخدام الإجراء الأخير لجعل
الرجال أكثر صراحة بشأن
فحصهم، ومرة ​​أخرى أعتقد أنه عندما
تتحدث عن تشخيصك وكفاحك فإنك تضفي
طابعًا إنسانيًا على نفسك
وأيضًا أنت  تحفيز الناس ليكونوا أكثر
استباقية فيما يتعلق بصحتهم، لذا
آمل أن يستخدم القصر هذا
كفرصة ليكونوا أكثر شفافية
ولمساعدتك على معرفة الجمهور البريطاني على
فهم أفضل لمكان تواجد ملكهم
الآن